en marge de cette actualité les états
unis qui depuis plus longtemps que la
france sont confrontés à la violence
dans l'école dans certains états comme
le connecticut on a décidé là bas tout
simplement de supprimer la mixité et de
rétablir certains y ont pensé d'ailleurs
en france les classes de filles d'un
côté deux garçons de l'autre
reportage pascal golomer tristan lebrun
l'uniforme est obligatoire que le
mercredi la séparation entre filles et
garçons en revanche c'est toute l'année
nous sommes pourtant dans un collège
public un collège qui depuis six ans
propose à quelques 160 élèves
volontaires une formule calquée sur
celle des institutions privées
mais ici c'est gratuit quelquefois les
garçons nous embête et nous manque de
respect au moins en étant séparés nous
sommes plus concentrés sur notre travail
en location avec les garçons les filles
ont un comportement plus effacé les
garçons prennent le 2 juin
si on sépare les classes s'affirme
davantage au bout du couloir les classes
des garçons effectif réduit la hausse
même programme intensif mêmes règles de
sélection
le collège recrute avant tout parmi les
plus défavorisés au sein de la
population noire de la ville il ne
choisit pas forcément les plus brillants
plutôt les plus motivés prêts à jouer
les élèves modèles pour toute la
communauté fière de présenter les
portraits des plus méritants affichés au
mur
mais si cela doit se faire sans mixité
c'est parce que les professeurs veulent
accorder aux uns et aux autres
toute l'attention qu'ils méritent
80 % des familles dans ces bruits sont
des familles sans peine ça crée des
problèmes différents pour les garçons et
pour les filles
ils vont donc nous aussi apporter des
réponses différentes s'est bien adapté
la répétition de la fanfare c'est l'un
des rares moments où garçons et filles
sont ensemble la plupart d'entre eux
iront au lycée l'an prochain avec des
résultats supérieurs à la moyenne
une expérience quasi unique dans le pays
que george bush veut désormais
encouragée subventionner le collège fox
en profitera pour ouvrir d'autres
classes persuadé démontrer ainsi aux
autres écoles publiques
l'exemple à suivre